The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
I'm going to continue
with frequency
response and filtering,
but also begin the story of
spectral content of signals.
So our starting point
is still something
you've seen before, namely
the statement that for an LTI
system, a sinusoid
into the system
gives you a sinusoid out
at the same frequency,
but maybe shifted in phase
and scaled in amplitude.
So a bit of terminology here
just for general interest,
we refer to the exponential
as an eigenfunction of the LTI
system, because the
only effect the LTI
system has on it a scaling.
So an input to some kind of
a mapping, which comes out
the same except for
a scaling is referred
to as an eigenfunction,
or an eigenvector
if you're talking
about matrices.
So we say that the exponential--
the complex exponential
here is an eigenfunction
of the LTI system.
Because when it comes through,
it's just the same exponential,
but scaled by some number.
And that number is what we refer
to as a frequency response,
right?
And we've seen that there's
a simple expression for it.
And let me put
that expression up,
because we're going
to use it repeatedly.
The m here is irrelevant.
It can be any dummy
index, because we're
summing over the m.
You can call it
anything you want.
And I just should
mention that there's
other notation for this object.
There are people
who refer to it as--
well, it's often referred
to as h of ej omega,
because actually, the way omega
enters is always in the term e
to the j omega.
So this is-- if you want
to think of it that way,
this is e to the j omega to
the power minus m, right?
Well, let me just write it as 1
over 1 over e to the j omega m.
OK, so it's some function
of e to the j omega.
And people will often
write it this way.
And one of the
advantages of this
is the notation
right away tells you
that this object is
periodic with period 2 pi.
Because if you were
to increase omega
by an integer multiple of
2 pi in the numerator here,
you'd get the same
argument again.
And therefore, h must
be the same again.
So this notation has
the value that it
keeps the periodicity
front and center.
It also makes sense
when you're developing
various other transforms.
There's something called
a z transform, which we
won't deal with in this class.
But it's used a lot when dealing
with discrete-time systems.
And the way that you
get from the z transform
to this object is by making the
substitution z equals ej omega.
So people will
use this notation.
So the z transform
uses z exactly where
we use e to the j omega.
But for our purposes, this
is a much simpler notation.
It's just that we need you
to remember when you see this
that we're talking
about something
that's got period 2 pi.
And if you look at the
definition, that becomes clear.
If you increase big
omega here by any integer
multiple of 2 pi, you're
going to get the same thing
back again.
There's another bit of
notational confusion that
can arise, which is that
people will sometimes
write little omega
instead of big omega.
So that's also used.
So this is other notation,
and it's notation
that we will try
not to use, but you
might see vestiges of this when
you look through old problems.
Because in some
terms, we may have
used this notation,
and some terms,
we may have used a little
omega instead of a big omega.
But for our purposes,
we'll stick to this.
OK, so when we say
big omega, we're
thinking of it as an angle
around the unit circle.
So if you've got the
complex number here
at an angle big omega,
this complex number
is e to the j omega, right?
So we're thinking of big
omega as an angle, something
measured in radians, and it's
different from little omega.
You can write the expression
for the frequency response
in various ways.
So here, I've just
used Euler's identity
to split that into
a cosine and a sine,
and that's
straightforward enough.
The sums are over
infinite intervals.
And we talked last time about
how stability of the system--
bounded input, bounded output
stability of the system
will guarantee that those
summations are well defined.
OK, now there's another
name for this formula.
Basically, we've called
it the frequency response.
But when you compute an h
of omega using this formula,
another way to say
what you're doing
is to say that you're taking the
discrete-time Fourier transform
of the sequence h dot, OK?
So it's the discrete-times
Fourier transform.
Again, that's just
terminology for now.
We'll come to expand
our view of it later.
But we've called it the
frequency response so far,
because it describes how
sinusoids or exponentials here
get to the output, but
it's also referred to
as the discrete-time Fourier
transform of the unit sample
response.
So you've got some time signal--
happens to be a unit
sample response.
You compute an object
through this formula
to get an h of omega.
That's the DTFT, OK?
Another thing we've
already seen is
that knowing that you
have an LTI system,
and that a cosine
is a superposition
of complex exponentials,
you can use the result
that we had so far
to just describe
what happens to a cosine when
it goes through the system.
So it's no longer a
complex exponential.
It's a real signal of
the kind that we're
more likely to work with.
And we've seen that the
only thing that happens
is the cosine that
went in gets scaled
in amplitude by an
extra factor, which
is the magnitude of
the frequency response.
And whatever phase it had,
you get an extra phase,
which is the angle of
the frequency response.
So actually, if you
had an LTI system,
this is a good way to measure
the frequency response
in the lab.
What you do is you
take your system there,
excite it with a sinusoid.
In continuous-time, we know we
can do that with an oscillator.
In discrete-time, you
generate a sequence like this.
And then look to see what
comes out of the system
and express it in this form, and
you'll label the scale factor
there as the magnitude
of the frequency response
and the extra phase angle as
the phase angle of the frequency
response.
So it makes for a
very systematic way
to probe a system and get
at the frequency response.
Again, of a point
that I've made before,
which is that when
you do this probing,
you only need to vary big omega
over the range minus pi to pi.
So when we write a frequency
response, because h of omega
is periodic with period 2 pi, we
only need to probe h of omega--
either the magnitude, that
would be one plot, and the angle
would be another plot.
Both of these would be
plotted from minus pi to pi.
Because outside of
that range-- well,
you can see it already
with the cosine.
If I added an integer
multiple of 2 pi to omega 0,
I'm going to get an integer
multiple of 2 pi added
into the argument of a cosine.
And I'm getting the
same cosine back again.
And the reason
that's the case is
because the n that's multiplying
it here is an integer.
So in continuous-time,
it doesn't
work quite the same way.
If I had a little omega 0t
and I added multiple of 2 pi,
I wouldn't get the same
argument back again.
So what's different here
is that if I increase omega
0 by an integer
multiple of 2 pi,
because I've got an
integer, and outside that,
again, I end up adding an
integer multiple of 2 pi,
and I'm back at the same cosine.
So frequency response for
a discrete-time system
is always in the
interval minus pi to pi.
It repeats periodically
outside of that if you chose
to look at some other omega.
And I've said that already.
You actually heard the
term frequency response
in all sorts of
settings, I'm sure.
One setting in which it's
used a lot is in describing,
for instance, the
performance characteristics
of a loudspeaker.
So people will tell you
how good their loudspeaker
is by showing you the frequency
response of the speaker.
And what they're
doing is they're
applying a sinusoidal
voltage to the input
and looking at the sound
pressure that comes out.
SPL here is sound
pressure level.
This is measured in
dB, so it's actually
a measurement of the
ratio of the pressure
that you hear under certain
standardized conditions
to a pressure which
is taken as the lowest
audible pressure on the ear.
So there's a
particular ratio there.
So what they'll do is
they'll feed the loudspeaker
with 1 watt at 1,000 Hertz,
so just a steady tone.
And then, a meter away from the
speaker in an anechoic chamber,
they'll look to see what
sound pressure they pick up
on a specialized sensor--
a detector, a
microphone basically--
and that number in dB is
what they'll represent.
And so typical speakers are--
have values in
that kind of range.
Now, if you probe it at
different frequencies
applying the same input voltage
and looking at pressure,
you'll get varying pressure
depending on the frequency
that you probe at.
So this is the frequency
response of the speaker,
and if you go too
low in frequency,
then you don't get
much of a response.
If you go to high
in frequency, you
don't get much of a response.
Now, of course, when
you use the speaker,
you're not going to probe
it with sines and cosines.
You're actually going to
put more complicated sounds
in there.
So what you're
really interested in
is how does the speaker
behave to signals that
are combinations of cosines?
And again, we're using our
model of the speaker as an LTI
system.
All bets are off if you drive
your speaker so hard that you
get distortion and exercise
all the nonlinearities there
or burn it out.
But if you're in a normal range,
the speaker is acting linearly,
you can talk about its
frequency response.
And what you're
really interested in
is how does the speaker
respond to linear combinations
of cosines?
And all of these various
signals can be thought of as--
at least over reasonable
time intervals--
as combinations of cosines
appropriately chosen.
So if you hit a particular
key on the piano,
you get a dominant note, but
you'll get harmonics of that.
And that's what's going
into your speaker.
So knowing how an LTI
system responds to cosines
then puts you in
a position to say
how it responds to
combinations of cosines,
or signals that are
combinations of cosines.
So the other part of the
story that we're going to get
to-- and maybe even by
the end of this lecture--
is we need a way to
take a general signal
and represent it as a
combination of cosines.
And that's what we refer
to as the spectral content
of the signal.
So when we talk of exposing the
spectral content of a signal,
as over here, what
we're saying is
we're going to show you what
combination of cosines it
takes to make up that signal.
And once you figure that out,
and you have the frequency
response of your LTI
system, you can say how
your system responds to that.
OK, so this theme runs
through every stage
of what happens, actually,
in communication.
Now, the example
I've given you here
is one that you
would typically probe
with a continuous-time
oscillator in the lab.
And so there's some
connections that you
might want to make
between probing
with a continuous-time
signal and probing
with a discrete-time
sequence that comes
from sampling that signal.
But I'm going to leave you to
look at that later or leave
your recitation instructors
to pull that back,
or leave you to draw this
up if you have a homework
problem that needs you to think
about how continuous-time maps
to discrete-time.
But the basic point is the
actual, physical speaker
you might probe with a
cosine in continuous-time,
if you're generating that signal
from a computer, what you'd
actually be sending
to your amplifier
is a sequence of numbers.
And the frequency of the
numbers that you would send,
this frequency is
related to the frequency
of the continuous-time
cosine that you
want in a very particular way.
So I'll leave you
to chew on that.
But I don't want to
spend time on that now.
OK, so let's spend a
little time talking
about the properties of
frequency response now
that we know why
we would use it.
And this I've already said.
The value of the
frequency response at--
some of this, by the way, you
may have seen in recitation.
But it doesn't hurt to repeat.
The frequency response
at frequency 0--
well, we've said if you've
got e to the j omega sub
0 and some frequency omega
sub zero going into a system h
omega, a system with
frequency response h omega,
an LTI system with frequency
response h omega-- all right,
I'm leaving out lots of words.
But frequency response
doesn't make sense
unless you have an LTI system.
OK, so for what
kind of input signal
would you be looking
at omega equals 0?
DC, right-- a constant signal.
It's what the
electrical engineers
call DC, which used to
stand for direct current
but has now come
to mean constant.
When we say a DC input, we
just mean a constant input.
So if I pick omega sub 0 to
be 0, then e to the j 0n,
well, that's just
one for all time.
And so I'm feeding the
system with a constant.
That's the slowest possible
input that you can find.
It's a 0 frequency input.
And the amount
that it's scaled by
is the number that you're
going to plot here.
So whatever value
you get is going
to end up being plotted
there at omega equals 0.
And let's see, do we believe
this other statement--
h0?
It's just a
substitution in here.
If I put omega equals 0, it's
a summation of all the hm's.
But there's another way
to think of it also.
If you want to think of
it in the time domain--
let's see.
I have an LTI system.
It's got some unit
sample response.
And I'm feeding it with an input
that's constant for all time.
It's actually constant at
the value 1 for all time.
If you're thinking in terms
of convolution, the flip slide
and dot product picture, what
is the output at any time here?
You're going to draw out
your unit sample response.
You're going to draw out your
input, which is 1 for all time,
take one of them and
flip it over, slide
it the appropriate
amount over the other,
and then take the dot product.
Well, for every shift of this
flipped and shifted input,
you're going to pick up all
of the unit sample response.
So every time, you're going
to get summation hm outside.
So if you fed an input
that was DC at the value 1,
this is what the output
will be at all times.
You can see that from
the convolution picture.
So what's the frequency
response at frequency 0?
What's the ratio of the
output to the input--
the output amplitude
to the input?
This is for all time.
So the input amplitude
was 1 at each time.
The output amplitude was that.
And so that's the DC gain--
the DC gain of the system, or
the frequency response at 0.
Let's say, so h0 is what's
referred to as the DC gain.
What about high frequency?
So what's the highest
frequency variation
that you can have with a
discrete time sequence?
I've got a sequence
here at the input.
We've seen what the slowest
variation possible is.
It's something that's constant.
If you're talking about a
discrete-time signal that
can only take values
at integer times,
what's the highest frequency
variation that you can get?
Just something that
alternates in sine, right?
So you're going to have--
OK, so is this of the
form e to the j omega
0n for some omega 0?
Is that a signal of
exponential form?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if you
take omega not equal to pi,
this is just e to the j pi n.
In fact, you can take
plus or minus pi.
So when you probe the
system with an input
of this type, which is
the highest frequency
input that you can probe
with, what you're really
probing is what's the frequency
response at this point?
You get the same value
at minus pi or pi.
So these are the two extremes.
And then the frequency
response, the rest of it
lies in between for
other sorts of inputs.
Now, do you believe this other
identity that I have up there?
Well, you can go back
to the definition, set
big omega equal
to pi or minus pi,
and you'll get an alternating
sequence of 1's and minus
1's here.
And so that verifies
that identity.
Or you can think in
terms of convolution.
If I convolve a sequence
like this with a system
with this unit sample response,
what comes out at every time
is an alternating sum of the
hm's, except the sine flips
from one time to the next.
And so, again, you can
verify in the time domain
that that's actually the high
frequency gain of the system,
OK?
Now, there's a bunch of
other symmetry properties
of the frequency
response that I think
in-- at least in some of
the recitations you've done.
And the easiest way to see
these symmetry properties
is to actually go
back to the rewriting
I did of the frequency response
in terms of sines and cosines.
This first term here
I'm calling C of omega.
The second term
here, the summation,
I'm calling S of omega.
So where would a statement
like this come from?
Let's see.
For real h of n, that's
the only kind of h of n
we're going to worry
about in general.
We're going to talk about
systems with real unit sample
responses.
if h is real, why
would it be true
that the real part of
the frequency response
is an even function
of frequency?
Well, the real part of
the frequency response
is this term, because the other
term is the imaginary part.
So the real part of
the frequency response
is this term.
And if I change big
omega to minus omega,
the cosine doesn't change.
It's the same.
And therefore, the
real part is even, OK?
So the real part of
the frequency response
is an even function of omega.
The imaginary part, which
is the minus S omega,
well if I change omega to
minus omega, I flip the sine.
So that's an odd function
of omega, and so on.
So you can go through
these properties.
Whenever you're stuck trying
to figure out a property,
this is the expression
to go back to.
So rewrite the basic
definition in this form,
and you'll understand
a lot of this.
And again, you'll get
practice in recitation
if you haven't
done that already.
Another important property of--
that you encounter when
you go from the time domain
to the frequency domain--
so remember, in
the time domain, we
said that if you have
an input here, you
convolve that input with
h1 to get the output
of the intermediate point?
OK, so if I call the output
of the intermediate point--
I should have done it there.
But here's h1.
If I call this w, this is x.
And then I go into
a second system, h2.
And here's y.
OK, well w is equal to
h1 convolved with x.
And y equals h2
convolved with w.
So that's this.
But I can put the parentheses
any way I like for convolution,
right?
We've already established
that property.
So the net effect of
the cascade of systems
is the effect you'd get by
having a single system LTI
with this unit sample response.
Now, if I think the
frequency domain--
if I put e to the j
omega n here, then
what comes out at the
intermediate point?
At the intermediate point,
I get h1 omega ej omega n.
All right, so that's wn.
But this is, again, an
input of exponential form.
So what comes out of
the second system when
I put this input into it?
So what's w of n-- sorry,
what's y of n going to be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so it's
basically the second system's
frequency response scaling
the exponential that
went into the second
system, which is this.
So the net effect when I put
ej omega in at the first spot
is at the output, I get
the same ej omega n,
but scaled by the product of
the two frequency responses.
So the nice thing
here is that when
I'm describing a
cascade of two systems,
if I describe the net
effect in the time domain,
I've got to do a convolution
of these two units' sample
responses.
If I think of it in
the frequency domain,
I just have to take the product
of the individual frequency
responses.
So the key observation
here is that convolution
in the time domain maps to
multiplication in the frequency
domain.
So if I wanted
the DTFT of this--
if I wanted the
discrete-time Fourier
transform of this
result of a convolution,
I can find it by
just multiplying
the individual DTFTs, all right?
So convolution in time maps to
multiplication in frequency.
And this actually makes
design much more easy,
because we're often cascading
systems in this form.
And if you think in
terms of frequency,
you can track a
frequency component
through a cascade
of such systems
just focusing on the frequency
response of each system
as you go.
So here's an example.
Suppose we have a channel.
Let's say that it's a channel
with an echo, so when I put--
let me actually
draw it out here.
So I've got a channel here
which I'm modeling as LTI.
And if I put in a
unit sample function
here, so this has the
value 1 at time 1,
suppose the channel is one
that has some echoing in it.
So what I actually
get out for this input
is the same delta of n plus
0.8 delta of n minus 1.
So there is a later
arrival scaled by something
which corresponds to the echo.
So this must be the unit
sample response of the channel.
What's the frequency
response of the channel?
So if I call this h1 of n,
what is h1 big of omega--
big omega-- h1 of big omega?
I don't have it up there, do I?
No.
Anyone?
Just from the definition.
Is the problem here
that you don't quite
see what h1, 0 is, h1,
1, h1, 2, and so on?
If I asked you to plot this
out, how would you plot it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Is it 1.8?
Where?
Where would you put the 1--
just over there?
Oh, you're talking about
the frequency response.
Let's get the unit
sample response first.
Let's sketch this.
What's your sketch of that?
AUDIENCE: At 0B1
PROFESSOR: At 0B1?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, on
0 everywhere else--
that's the unit sample response.
OK, so what's the
frequency response?
Well, we just plug it
into the definition.
All the h's except the ones that
argue in 0 on 1 are equal to 0.
So this is going to be 1 plus
0.8 to the minus j omega.
Is that what you said?
It was not quite
what you said, right?
What you said was the
number I'd get at omega
equals 0-- the DC
gain of the system.
But the frequency
response is that.
Let's just work backwards here.
So the frequency
response is that.
Or if I wanted to write it--
we're going from
that board to here--
h1 of omega, I can write it
as a real plus imaginary part.
So it would be 1 plus
0.8 cosine omega.
This would be the real part.
Then I have a minus j--
sorry, 0.8 sine omega.
OK, so that's the
frequency response--
some complex number with a real
part and an imaginary part.
OK, and if I asked you to give
it to me in magnitude and angle
form, you could do that.
It's just rearranging things.
So you'd-- the magnitude would
be the square root of the sum
of squares of these two pieces.
And the angle would be
the arctan of the ratio.
So I assume that you know
how to do all of that.
And what you find--
actually, you
can see it in these
expressions already.
Just as-- well, I didn't
quite claim this earlier.
But the magnitude of
the frequency response
will always be a real
function of frequency-- sorry,
an even function of frequency.
And the phase will always be
an odd function of frequency.
So if you're drawing the results
of a computation like this
and you find that you
don't have an even function
for the magnitude, then you know
you've done something wrong.
So I'm not-- I'm going
to sketch something here
which I'm not pretending
is the magnitude of that.
I just want you to get the
idea of what I mean by even.
It's going to be something
that's symmetric in omega.
This is the magnitude.
And then, if I did
the phase, the phase
is always going to
be something that's
an odd function of frequency.
So if it's an odd
function of frequency,
what's the value
at 0 of the phase?
It's got to go through 0, right?
And so I might get--
well, what would it actually be?
It would be some shape.
I'm not pretending I have
the right shape here.
But it's going to
have an odd symmetry.
I'll leave you to figure out
what it actually looks like.
So that's the frequency
response of this echo channel.
So here's what I
want you to do now.
At your receiver, build
for me a filter that's
going to undo the distortion
that the echo has produced.
So what I'd like is,
I'd like an output,
after you've done
your filtering, to be
exactly equal to the input.
So my question is, what should--
and my claim is you can do
that with an LTI filter.
How would you describe
that LTI filter?
What should that LTI filter be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, OK, so
if you wanted the output
to be exactly
equal to the input,
no matter what input was, you
want a frequency response of 1
overall.
And the overall frequency
response we know
is the product of the
two individual ones.
And so we want h2 omega times
h1 omega to be equal to 1.
And therefore, h2
should be 1 over h1.
So you can see here how things
get a lot easier when you
think in the frequency domain.
If I had to do this
in the time domain,
I would have had
to say h2 convolved
with h1 has got to give me
the unit sample function.
And I'll give you h1, now
you've got to figure h2.
Well, you've got to go and
work the convolution picture
backwards, which is
doable for simple cases.
But this is much simpler.
So this shows that h2
should be 1 over h1.
Seems like a
reasonable way to go.
And you can actually work
the whole thing through.
But there's a problem with this.
And we've seen this
in other settings
as well, which is
something that works
fine in the noise-free
case doesn't
work so well when you've
got noise in your system.
So look at what this
receiver filter is doing.
The receiver filter-- let's
see, what is its magnitude?
How does the magnitude
of the receiver filter
relate to the magnitude
of the channel filter--
of the channel
frequency response?
So this magnitude is a
magnitude of 1 over h1.
Is that the same as 1
over magnitude of h1?
Is that how complex
numbers work?
OK, right?
So look what happens.
Where the channel has a very
low frequency response--
in other words, where the
channel output is very
low for a sinusoidal
input at that frequency,
the receiver filter is going
to have a very high magnitude.
So the receiver filter
is trying to boost up
whatever signal it sees
in a frequency range
where the channel actually
has very little output.
So what happens if I come
and have a bit of noise
here where I'm
receiving the signal?
Well, it's going to be
very badly exaggerated
by the inverse filter.
So a little bit
of noise here will
get accentuated at
frequencies where
the frequency response of
the receiver filter is large.
But that's precisely
where the channel had
a very low frequency response.
And it's precisely where
the output-- the channel--
has nothing interesting for me.
So my receiver filter ends
up accentuating the noise.
OK, so yet again, we
see that these sorts
of inversion operations
may look nice on paper.
But if you don't take
account of what noise does,
then you can run into trouble.
And the picture is
very transparent
when you think in
the frequency domain.
OK, some more practice
with filters and cascade--
I think I'm going to leave
you to work through this
in recitation, perhaps.
So I'll leave it on the slides.
But let's go to
design of filters.
So now, we've seen one example
of trying to design a filter--
the receiver filter-- to undo
the distortion of the channel.
Here's another--
actually, I want that.
Here is another design
problem that you
run into all the time, which
is that you see a signal that's
got a whole bunch of
frequencies mixed up in it,
and you want to
exclude some of them.
So maybe you're looking
for an audio signal.
You know that the
combinations of sinusoids
that make up an audio signal
are unlikely to go above--
whatever you want.
Pick your number-- 10
kilohertz, 20 kilohertz.
And so you want to exclude
frequencies outside
of that range.
So you're very often
in the position
of trying to build what's
called an ideal low pass filter.
So here's an ideal
low pass filter.
I'd like you to build
for me a filter that
passes all frequencies in
some range without distortion,
and that completely
kills everything outside.
So let me call this
the cutoff frequency.
So that's the h of omega I want.
And now my question is, how are
you going to build this filter?
I want you to give
me the unit sample
response that goes with it.
And you see a hint over here.
But can you tell me how
you might go about that?
Not so obvious, right?
Because we've specified
the filter characteristic
in the frequency domain, and
now we want to find the h's
that go with it.
So what we're really
looking for is a formula
that will give us the time
domain signal in terms
of the frequency domain.
So we want to
invert this somehow.
So what we're
looking for is really
what's called the inverse DTFT.
And actually, if you've
done Fourier series,
you've seen this trick before.
Because really, we're not
far from Fourier series here.
It's just that the domains
are a little different,
so maybe you don't recognize it.
Here, we've got a periodic
something expressed
as a combination of
sines and cosines,
or as a combination
of exponentials.
And now, we want
to invert that, OK?
If you thought of these
as Fourier coefficients
for some periodic signal,
and then went and looked up
whatever book you use
for Fourier series,
you'd get the formula.
Because we're just trying
to extract the Fourier
coefficients for
this periodic signal.
But you can actually
do it from scratch.
So if you think of multiplying
both sides of this by,
let's say, e to the j omega n--
OK, so I'm going to
multiply both sides.
So I've got e to the minus j
omega m minus n now, right?
And I'm going to then integrate
both sides over an interval
of length 2 pi--
any contiguous interval
of length 2 pi.
It actually does matter
because of the periodicity.
So I'll take any
interval of length 2 pi
and I integrate both sides.
And I'll assume that I can
hop this integral in there.
I'll assume my signal is
well-behaved enough for that.
So here's what I end up getting.
On this right hand side, I
get summation integral hm.
Oh, I should put
a d omega there.
Sorry.
I've gotten casual
with my integration.
So on this side, I
have this integral.
On this side, I
have that integral.
And if you work
through this, out
of all this infinity
of terms, there's
only one term that survives.
Because any term in which
m is different from n
will have this exponential
still sitting here.
This exponential is like
a cosine plus a j sine,
or a cosine minus a j sine.
You're integrating it
over an interval of 2 pi.
So any term here that
has the exponential,
or has the sine or cosine
in it, will disappear
under the integration.
The only term that survives
is the one where m equals n.
And so what you
discover is that this is
2 pi hn when you're all done.
I'm not going through
the details here.
So here is the formula we
wanted for the inverse DTFT.
Here's the inverse DTFT, OK?
I've forgotten my colored
chalk today, but that'll do.
So if I gave you a filter
characteristic like this
and asked you to find the unit
sample response of the filter
that went with it, you
would just have to plug
in the frequency response
characteristic that I gave you
and solve for the h's.
I think I have a bunch
of this on the slides.
This is what we
just went through.
So let's do this now for
the ideal low pass filter.
What is it that we do?
I've got the formula that I
just derived for you there.
h is equal to 1 in the
pass band of the filter,
and it's 0 outside of that.
So I set h equal to 1 in the
pass band of the filter, which
is from minus omega C to plus
omega C, and the rest of it
doesn't contribute anything.
And then, I just work
out this integral.
And I've actually got
to do it in two pieces.
For n not equal to 0,
this is what I get.
For n equals 0,
If n was continuous,
actually, you'd
say that this is the
same expression as here,
because you just
use L'Hopital's rule
and you'll get
from here to here.
But since n is an
integer, we've got
to be a little careful
how we write it, OK?
So you can't really say you're
going to use L'Hopital's rule
to see what this is in
the limit of n going to 0,
because n takes integer values.
But if you work it out from
scratch for n equals 0,
you'll see that you
get a formula that's
consistent with using
L'Hopital's rule.
OK, so this is a function that
we'll see again and again when
we do filtering of
this type, and it's
referred to as a sinc function.
So it's not S-I-N, but S-I-N-C.
And if you plot it out,
this is what it is.
So it's got the oscilation
that comes from the sine,
but it's got a reduction in
amplitude that comes from the 1
over n.
So it's a signal
that falls off as 1
over n with this kind
of a characteristic.
Do you think it's a bounded
input, bounded output
stable system?
What's your hunch?
Remember what it takes
for a system to be stable?
The unit sample response has
to be absolutely summable.
So if you take the
absolute values here,
and sum from minus
infinity to infinity,
you want to get something
finite to call this stable.
Well, since this only
falls off as 1 over n,
it turns out to not be stable.
So it's actually an
extreme idealization
that is not bounded-- input
bounded, output stable,
but it's close.
Just to go back when I showed
you this filter characteristic
here, to give the cheap version
of a low pass filter, what
we actually did was
take the sinc function
and truncated to
a finite interval.
And so what happens when
you truncate it to a finite
interval is that instead
of the sharp box-like shape
for the frequency response,
you get a closer approximation
to it--
not exactly the ideal low pass
filter, but maybe good enough.
The other thing that
you might notice
if you're looking carefully
is that I had a sinc that
was centered around 0 and even.
And now, I seem to have a
causal version of the filter.
And I think I'll leave you
in recitation to figure out
how you can go from the
centered, non-causal filter
to a causal filter,
and what that
does to phase and to
frequency response magnitude.
So basically, I'll leave you
to go through the details here.
But the key idea here
is the inverse DTFT.
So now, I want to just take a
slightly different perspective
on this formula that we derived.
We said we've got a frequency
response, which we're
calling the DTFT of the signal
h of n-- the unit sample
response.
We've got an
inverse formula that
allows us to get the time signal
from the frequency response.
But here's yet another
way of looking at what
this formula is telling us.
This formula is saying,
I can think of h of n
as being made up of a whole
bunch of complex exponentials.
So you see that this is
what we were looking for.
We were looking for a
way to take a signal
and figure out its
spectral content.
We want to know what
complex exponentials,
or what sinusoids does it
take to make that signal?
Well, we have a hint of
that in this expression,
because this is saying,
take the time domain signal.
I can think of it as
being a combination.
Now, this is not a finite
combination, it's a continuum.
But it is a combination of
exponentials of the type
that we know to work with.
So this is actually giving
us a spectral decomposition
of the unit sample
response, where
the amount of e to
the j omega n that it
takes to make up the signal
is told to me by h of omega.
So the h of omegas are
sort of the weights
that we use to combine these
exponentials to get the signal.
So the idea for a
spectral decomposition,
or for describing the
spectral nature of a signal
is actually sitting there.
All we have to do is say,
we'll use the same formulas,
but let's no longer restrict
it to the unit sample
response of a system
and the frequency
response of that system.
Let's use it for any signal--
so the same formulas, but
now for any signal xn.
Give me any signal xn,
I'll compute for you
this object, which is the
DTFT of that signal, just
the same way I did for
a frequency response.
So I'll compute the
x of omega for you.
What's the significance
of x of omega?
Well, it tells me
in what combination
I have to wait the
e to the j omega n's
to construct for you the signal.
So the x of big omega,
the DTFT tells me
what the spectral
content of the signal is.
If I plot that as a
function of frequency,
it tells me how to
assemble the signal out
of sums of sines and cosines.
So let's see here.
More specifically, what I would
say is that the DTFT at omega
0--
omega sub 0 times d omega
is the spectral content
of the signal in that
particular interval.
And if I add up all those
components over all frequencies
in this 2 pi range, I'll
get the original signal
that I'm interested in.
So what we'll do next time
is work with this idea
to see how it lets us think
about signals through systems,
and how it enables us to do
filtering in a systematic way.
All right, let's leave
it at that for now.